Fox News Alert moments ago there was an
outburst at the Palestine Ohio Town Hall
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
the people of East Palestine showed up
to the town hall thinking the company
that dropped a toxic bomb on their town
would be there
but Norfolk Southern and its cowardly
CEO Alan Shaw backed out they're hiding
from the residents after turning their
Town into little Chernobyl in prime time
talk to the people in East Palestine
listen
are you experiencing any symptoms a
little light-headed and my lips did get
all tingly yesterday when we went to
clean up the house it smells terrible up
around the house and it is black residue
on the pictures surface stuff I hit a
cloud of something down in there that it
put me in I went to the hospital that
was worried about me having a I've been
so stressed out they would they put me
on an EKG thinking I'm going to have a
freaking heart attack
because of my stress being so high I
want to know what I sucked in I've just
throat felt like there was gravel in it
I mean it was just I had a sore throat
since then I I vomit within 10 minutes
of being in that home the air is still
terrible absolutely terrible I will not
take my children in there because of
that yeah yeah burning of the eyes
trouble breathing and then I just get
nauseous within 10 minutes you know my
husband popped in to try to get anything
you know phone charger things that they
say are safe you cannot get the smell
out it does not come out my kids as
friends said they lost cats they you
know their pets have been you know sick
and then we have kids as friends who
have rashes and my daughter was one that
also had a real bad looks almost like a
sunburn BPA is letting us you know
giving us numb or not giving us any
numbers so they're just saying that the
air is clean we know we've heard that
before 9 11. the water was fine in Flint
Michigan different things so that is in
the back of your head they told me they
were going to do an air quality test
never going to call back three times
three different Agents from that number
said they were coming to do an air
quality test you know if I could I would
definitely move I'm old I'm not ready to
die but
I hope I don't have any After Effects is
what worries me Ohio Congressman Bill
Johnson represents East Palestine so
Congressman are you're there at the Town
Hall situation what is the mood like
after the CEO didn't show up
uh people are very frustrated people are
angry Jesse they came here for answers
and and they're legitimately frustrated
uh that the company that uh caused this
accident is not here to be accountable
but I can tell you what I am here and
I'm going to stay here I was here on
Monday I walked around with the mayor
the the fire chief some of the emergency
crews the EPA
representatives of Norfolk Southern I'm
going to stay here and if if the the
railroad's not here tonight but I'm
taking their questions and anybody
that's got a question for Norfolk
Southern that they can't get to them
tonight I will take their question and
make sure that they get an answer well I
have a question if you could ask Norfolk
Southern
are they going into people's homes and
making them sign liability waivers in
order to test the water
you know I haven't heard that I haven't
seen that I'm going to ask about that
when I talk to uh when I get out of here
tonight tonight's the first time that
I've heard that but I have not heard
that from uh from any of the residences
here can I give you another question can
you ask the EPA if they did their own
testing because we're hearing that
Norfolk Southern hired a private
contractor to do all the testing and you
know what it means when they hire a
private contractor and they get the
results that they want
yeah I will go back and ask the EPA that
it's my understanding that the EPA has
overseen uh all of the testing uh I mean
they're the ones responsible for
enforcement of the Clean Air Act and the
Clean Water Act so legitimately they
should be the ones that's pulling the
trigger on the testing and validating
that the testing is being done uh
properly but I the regional director is
here I understand the EPA administrator
is going to be here tomorrow so yes I
will I will find out about that but it's
the first time tonight that I've heard
anything about waivers of liability okay
well please send my love to everybody in
the town and they have our support and
we're not going to stop covering the
story and and thank you Congressman for
what you're doing you seem to be really
on top of it and and thanks for
communicating everything to us and
communicating our questions to the
people
Jesse thanks for giving me a chance to
to be on we'll go back in and continue
the work all right please do thank you
hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now